welcome to the David Pakman show I am of
course not David Pakman I am Benjamin
Dixon host of the podcast the Benjamin
Dixon show you could find me anywhere
you find podcast David is out of town
and he will be back tomorrow and in the
meantime we have a lot of news to cover
of course we have to begin the day with
the President of the United States
Donald Trump who has once again inserted
himself into the legal process
surrounding the malla probe I want to
bring up a tweet that the president
shared early this morning and this is
what he had to say he said this is a
terrible situation and Anthony Attorney
General Jeff Sessions should stop this
rigged witch-hunt right now before it
continues to stay in our country any
further Bob Muller is totally conflicted
and his 17 angry Democrats that are
doing his dirty work are a disgrace to
the United States that's how he started
he continued with the next tweet this is
what he had to say he said Paul Manafort
worked for Ronald Reagan Bob Dole and
many other highly prominent and
respected political leaders he worked
for me for a very short time why didn't
the government tell me that he was under
investigation these old charges have
nothing to do with collusion a hoax all
right we'll stop right there with those
two tweets so the president has already
you know he's done this before
he's inserted himself into the process
but this is the first time that he's
directly called
for Attorney General Jeff Sessions to
put it into this you will recall last
week in the week before that Republicans
started the process of impeaching Rod
Rosenstein because of this investigation
and the president is getting nervous if
you if you see his behavior patterns if
you see what he's doing he's making the
mistakes and it bear it's very likely
that he is going to implicate himself
with his actions at this point it's the
same you know the saying that it's not
the crime that gets you it's the
cover-up and that's what the president
is doing here
now he's of course labeling it in
witch-hunt that's what he does he labels
everything a hoax anything that he
disagrees with is considered a hoax but
this is like I said before this is the
first time that he is outright called
for Jeff Sessions to put it into this
thankfully Jeff Sessions doesn't have
the ability to put an end to this
because he has recused himself from this
process but underneath all of this is
what the president is actually trying to
do he
trying to win this in the court of
public opinion he knows that if he can
make this issue as hyper-partisan as
possible then it's very likely that
nothing will be done even if Muller
turns up something sensitive something
that implicates him now as it stands
right now there's not a lot of evidence
that we've been privy to publicly that
implicates the president directly I
think the closest thing we have now is
Donald Trump jr. where it's come out
that the president knew about the the
meeting with Russian operatives at the
Trump Tower previously Trump jr. told
the Congress that the president did not
know about it and so the highest level
of ramifications so far really rests
with Donald Trump jr. and the
possibility of perjury but that still
hasn't stopped the President of the
United States from being bold enough and
brash enough to insert himself in the
process in a very direct fashion this
unless you know that we're way past we
were so far beyond any standardized
norms any sense of protocol any any
concern for the appearance of letting
justice carry its carry its way out you
know we're well past that point at this
point it's a free-for-all and the
president has decided to wage his war
against Bob Muller and the Department of
Justice his Department of Justice and
before I even finish that sentence we
have to point this out right
the irony the the biggest irony in all
of this is that this is Bob Muller who
was a Republican Rod Rosenstein who is a
Republican or at least was appointed by
Republicans you have a Republican
Department of Justice headed up by a
Republican Attorney General who was
appointed by a Republican president and
they are waging a war against their own
but they're swearing that this is all a
result of the Democratic Party I want to
bring up the last tweet from Donald
Trump this morning on the issue he said
Russian collusion with the Trump
campaign one of the most successful in
history is a total hoax the Democrats
paid for the phony and discredited
dossier which is which was alone would
call me McCabe's strokes and and his
lover hit be lovely lisa page used to
begin the witch-hunt disgraceful
disgraceful it's a little difficult
reading the President of the United
States because of the absurd things that
he says but but the fact that matter is
that he's still spreading himself fake
news the dossier the origins of the
dossier goes back to a Republican
operative that was trying to do research
on opposition research on Donald Trump
that's been proven but that doesn't stop
the President of the United States from
spreading his own fake news from from
doing everything that he can to muddy
the waters because he knows this thing
to be true
he knows that people who love Him and
still support him no matter what he's
done so far they don't care about the
truth they don't care that the dossier
actually had origins in the Republican
Party they are going to continue to say
the same lie that it started with with
Hillary Clinton and started with
Democrats if they're gonna continue to
push that because the President of the
United States continues to push that
same lie so here we are with which
stories that in any other administration
would be enough to bring that
administration to a complete gridlock
but this is the unique strength of
Donald Trump this is a unique ability
his uncanny gift if he's talented in
anything it's not being a businessman
it's not being a leader it's his his
unfettered shamelessness his ability to
go further and further and further to
destroy any sense of shame that this
country has and we are not even in a
position to actually process this we're
dealing with the president who throws so
many different ridiculous situations in
at us in a single news cycle that we
can't even really adjust to to consider
how significant what just happened
really is I mean there's there's been
new cycles where in one day we have five
stories that in any other administration
would have brought that administration
down but for Donald Trump it's just the
12 o'clock news break and that's his
uncanny gift and this is why when
everyone was saying I don't know if you
recall earlier in the administration
people kept tweeting and kept saying
this can't be the new normal this isn't
the new normal the reality of it is is
that this is the new normal because we
have all gotten adjusted to it we've all
gotten accustomed to the President of
the United
States being involved in any number of
scandals that would have brought down
any administration I don't care democrat
or republican what the President of the
United States is mired in right now is
enough was enough to bring down any
previous administration and yet he just
keeps trudging through his own swamp
that he's supposed to be emptying out